monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur gérard cherpion pour le groupe
les remercie madame la présidente je
regrette monsieur le premier ministre
que vous n'ayez pas répondu à la
question de notre collègue claude
goasguen
où est la république exemplaire voulue
par le président candidat au lond mois
après mois la france s'enfonce dans le
chômage monsieur le premier ministre
3 millions 850 1900 demandeurs d'emploi
de catégorie à 5 millions à 470 mille
600 demandeurs d'emplois toutes
catégories ce sont quarante deux mille
demandeurs d'emploi de plus pour le mois
dernier auxquels il faut ajouter les 42
1800 radiations administratives qui sont
un moyen pour vous de limiter la casse
la france poursuit sa régression en
matière économique
ainsi notre place de premier partenaire
économique de l'allemagne nous a été
ravie par les etats unis se sont donc
nouvelles pertes d'emplois les résultats
des élections régionales montre une
exaspération des françaises et des
français face à ce manque de résultats
de votre gouvernement
face à cela monsieur le premier ministre
vous annoncer sur un plateau télévisé un
énième plan massif de l'emploi pour
l'année prochaine
pourtant la situation est dramatique
vous annoncer un plan de formation des
demandeurs d'emploi ou et votre réforme
de la formation professionnelle de 2014
qui devait tout régler
pourquoi avoir saccagé l'apprentissage
véritable formation de réussite et
d'excellence qui est en baisse constante
depuis 2002
monsieur le premier ministre d'annoncer
en annonce la france recule et les
français souffrent comment on pouvait
vous annoncez un énième plan alors que
vous n'êtes pas capables de remplir des
postes essentiels dans l'administration
ainsi depuis près de quatre mois la
délégation générale à l'emploi la
formation professionnelle la dgefp bras
armé du gouvernement dans la lutte
contre le chômage et pour la création
d'emplois et ce en tête un délégué
général n'a pas été remplacé pas plus
que le responsable du département des
synthèses dit le chargé de mission à
l'indemnisation du chômage
la vacance de ces postes essentiels pour
la mise en oeuvre de vos politiques qui
est de votre responsabilité démontre
votre incapacité de passer des paroles
aux actes monsieur le premier ministre
quand allez vous enfin cesser la
communication à outrance pour trouver
des réponses concrètes à la première
préoccupation des français l'emploi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
mme anna ministre de l'emploi la
dernière présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député gérard cherpion oui
en effet il y à une urgence certes
urgence a été rappelé et bien sûr
dimanche soir mais cette urgence demande
bien sûr et aussi une mobilisation
républicaine
vous le savez la reprise économique est
là mais elle est encore insuffisante
il faut il faut nous avons eu en un an
quarante mille créations nettes
d'emplois nous connaissons notre
croissance démographique et il faudrait
en effet après de nombreuses années de
destruction nette d'emplois nous avons
depuis un an
quarante mille créations nettes
d'emplois et nous le savons pour faire
reculer durablement le chômage il faut
minimum 120 mille créations nettes
d'emplois pour répondre à notre défi
démographique
donc nous savons nous avons mis en place
des réformes structurelles
le pack de responsabilité le cic eux qui
nous permet justement aux entreprises de
retrouver confiance
mais il y à des réalités dans le pays
qu'il faut regarder en face quand on
regarde la situation de notre chômage
qui est un chômage de peu ou pas
qualifiés nous avons en effet près de
deux millions de demandeurs d'emploi qui
n'ont pas le niveau qu'ils ont le niveau
bac et près de 680 milles qui ont un
niveau inférieur au ca paix et je crois
que c'est une réalité en matière
d'apprentissage en matière de formation
et demandeurs d'emploi
il faut que nous allions bien au delà le
pré de millet ministre l'a 10 et 12 ans
auront l'occasion avec toutes les
régions qui souhaitent le faire avec
nous nous avons l'occasion en effet de
prendre ensemble des mesures radicales
pour améliorer les choses parce que
l'apprentissage reste une voie
d'excellence
nous avons une petite augmentation pas
suffisante en effet mais nous avons
aussi des questions qui se posent à
l'ensemble des français
la valorisation des métiers manuels ça
fait 30 ans que nous en parlons dans
notre pays
si nous ne prenons pas en compte
notamment dans l'industrie
la difficulté de l'attractivité de ses
métiers nous sommes en capacité et donc
c'est ce front républicain qu'il faut
c'est mettre en oeuvre un aléa d'évoquer
madame la ministre pardon